المترجم: Sundos Hammoud
المدقّق: Ghalia Turki
مرحباً،
أؤمن تماماً أن الأغنية
لا يمكن أن تُغنى بلا سبب،
وأن القصيدة تحمل خلفها حساً خفياً
ودافعاً عميقاً في روح الكاتب،
وأن المشروع حينما يولد
يكون قد مر بالتفكير ألف مرة،
وأن الصلاة تنطوي على مناجاة
سابقات ساقتها نحو الأداء.
هذا ما كتبته على غلاف ديواني الشعري الأول
"ألف إنسان في روح واحدة"
الذي هو قيد النشر حالياً.
صراحةً، حين اخترت العنوان
كانت لدي مشكلة كبيرة،
احترت كثيراً حتى أجد العنوان
الذي يمكن أن يعبر عني،
وعن قصائد كتبتها منذ أن تشكلت مبادئي
وعبرت عنها من خلال الشعر حين
كنت في السادسة عشر من عمري.
في النهاية حين قررت تسميته
"ألف إنسان في روح واحدة"
كنتُ فعلاً أعبر عن نفسي
بأن حياةً واحدة لا تكفي.
منذ كنت صغيرة، كانت والدتي
-حفظ الله أهاليكم- ووالدي
مهتمين بأن يعرفوا مدى الإمكانيات
والطاقات التي عند أولادهم
ورغبوا بأن يعلمونا اكتشاف هذه الإمكانيات
والطاقات عن طريق تعلم كل شيء.
فكانت أيامنا عبارة عن رياضة، موسيقا،
مطالعة ونشاطات أخرى.
إلى أن تعلمت أن اليوم الذي
يمر لا يمكن أبداً أن يتكرر،
ووُضِعت في التحدي الأول:
ولأن مَن يخاف مِن الوحش
سيظهر الوحش في طريقه،
كانت سنة اختبارات الترشح
للدورة الرياضية العربية
الحادية عشر برياضة البنداثلون،
وفي نفس السنة كنتُ في الصف التاسع،
والتاسع -كما تعلمون- شهادة
يحسب السوريون لها حساباً.
فكان لدي خياران:
أن أضيع فرصة البطولة التي
لا تتكرر إلا مرة كل أربع سنوات،
وأن أركز على دراستي، لأن دراستي مستقبلي.
أو أن الدراسة يُتدَبّر أمرها،
ويجب أن أذهب إلى البطولة
حتى لا أضيع الفرصة.
عندما حان الوقت لأختار،
اخترت الخيار الثالث،
هل يمكن ذلك؟ لِمَ لا؟
كنت أذهب صباحاً لأداوم في المدرسة،
ثم أتدرب 6 ساعات يومياً،
ثم أعود إلى المنزل لأدرس.
في نهاية العام كنت قد حصلت على فضية
الدورة العربية برياضة البنداثلون.
وعلى 304/310، أي ما يعادل
98% من نتيجة التاسع.
حينها فقط، أدركت أن الفرق
بين الممكن والمستحيل
هو إرادة الشخص نفسه.
في عام 2010، كان لدي
الإيمان والرغبة بالحجاب،
لكن للأسف تاريخ السبّاحات لا يبشر بالخير.
كل سبّاحة تقرر أن تتحجب،
كانت تعتزل السباحة
وتنتهي مسيرتها الرياضية.
لكن بما أن المبدأ الصحيح، سواء
كان الفكري، الديني أو الأخلاقي
لا يمكن أن يتعارض مع محبتنا
للمجالات التي تؤدي إلى الإنجاز.
ذهبت إلى سوق الحريقة "سوق أقمشة"،
اشتريت قماشاً،
وصممت بدلة سباحة، فأصبحت
أول سبّاحة سورية محجبة،
وواحدة من ثلاث لاعبات
ترياثلون محجبات بالعالم.
(تصفيق)
ذلك الإنجاز الذي تشعر به عادةً،
لم أشعر به!
لا تستطيع أن تشعر بالإنجاز مالم تساعد
غيرك على تعلمه وتحقيق مثله.
كل متدرب في أي مجال
قادر على أن يصبح مدرباً.
في بداية المرحلة الجامعية
حصلت على شهادات تدريب
في مختلف المجالات التي كنت فيها متدربة.
وفي أول فرصة، تطوعت في جمعية
"إيماء" لخدمة الصم والبكم،
وتطوعت بمؤسسة الأولمبياد الخاص
لتدريب ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصة الذهنية.
دربت فريقَي السباحة والتزلج المدولب الوطني
وشاركنا في بطولة العالم في "لوس أنجلوس"
للأولمبياد الخاص عام 2015
وحصلنا على ست ميداليات ذهبية.
كنت المدربة الأصغر في هذه البطولة
وكنت المدربة الأكثر فرحاً
لأنني استطعت إيصال لاعبيّ إلى
المنصة التي وقفت عليها يوماً.
هذا العطاء، أن تستطيع تقديم
شيء ما للمجال الذي قدم لك الكثير،
الرياضة قدمت لي الكثير؛
فرحة الإنجاز، كانت كافية بالنسبة لي
لتدفعني لتقديم أي شيء بالمقابل.
جميع المجالات تقدم لنا،
الشعر قدم لي كثيراً،
منذ كنت في السادسة عشر من عمري،
الأدب بشكل عام هو الذي يعطي الفرصة للشباب
لأن يكتبوا وأن يعبروا عن أنفسهم وقضاياهم،
عن الأشياء التي يودون إخبارها للعالم
بلغة جميلة وأسلوب لطيف وقابل للطرح.
اجتمعت مع مجموعة من الشباب،
كنا جميعاً نمتلك نفس الامتنان
لعالم الأدب الذي قدم لنا الكثير.
وقررنا أن نؤسس مجموعة "مدى"
للفكر والثقافة والفنون.
كان هدف هذه المجموعة أن
تقدم شيئاً لم يقدمه أحد من قبل،
بطريقة لم يستخدمها أحد من قبل،
لإيصال فكرة لم يسبق العمل عليها،
إلى أشخاص لم يعرفوا من قبل
أي شيء عن هذه الفكرة.
أقمنا عدة فعاليات واحتفاليات مختلفة،
كان أبرزها عندما جربنا للمرة الأولى
وبدون أي إمكانيات أكاديمية،
تأليف وإخراج مسرحية "سطور من ماء"
التي تحدثت عن جوانب أغفلتها عدة نصوص وكتب
عن حياة الأديب جبران خليل جبران.
تمت تأدية المسرحية على مسارح دمشق.
كانت التجربة المسرحية الأولى
وأديت فيها دور ماري هاسكل.
عندما قدم الشعر لنا الكثير،
كان عالم الأدب يؤثر في حياتنا
فحاولنا التأثير به.
في الحقيقة، كل العالم كذلك،
نحن نؤثر ونتأثر.
في النهاية هذا هو المجتمع،
أصدقاء، أقارب وأخوة،
في النهاية جميعنا نؤثر ببعض
للحصول على نتيجة لطيفة.
أختي كانت من أوائل الناس
الذين عملوا على مشروع
تعليم تقنية الويكي في سورية.
عندما علمتني، أقمنا ورشات
ونظمنا مجموعات عمل
تستطيع تعلم تقنية الويكي التي تعمل
بها موسوعة الويكيبيديا العالمية
التي تقوم على مفهوم التعاون والتشاركية،
لنستطيع رفد المحتوى العالمي
سواء كان العلمي أو المعرفي
وخصوصاً العربي على الإنترنت.
هل لديكم فكرة عن نسبة المحتوى
العربي على الإنترنت؟
(محاولات إجابة من الجمهور)
سمعت إجابات صحيحة،
كان 1% وعرفت بالأمس أنه أصبح 3%.
3% هو المحتوى العربي على الإنترنت
بالرغم من أن عدد المتحدثين
باللغة العربية هو 467 مليون متحدث
واللغة العربية هي اللغة الرابعة عالمياً.
لاابد وأن نجتهد أكثر!
حاولنا رفد المحتوى العربي على
الانترنت خصوصاً المحتوى العلمي
حتى عندما نكون بحاجة إلى
معلومة علمية لا نضطر لأن نبحث
عن مرجع ومصادر ونترجمها
لأنها غير متوفرة بلغتنا.
لم يتم العمل على هذا
المشروع في سورية فقط،
بل عُمل به في عدة بلدان عربية.
وحالياً توجد عدة موسوعات
معرفية باللغة العربية
وباللغات الأخرى تنتظر مشاركتكم بها
لأنها جميعها تعمل بتقنية wiki
وهي تحتاج إلى تشاركية وعمل.
الـ wiki في النهاية هو تكنولوجيا،
ومن منا لا يهتم بالتكنولوجيا؟!
التكنولوجيا الثورة العظيمة
التي بدأت في القرن العشرين،
والآن في القرن الواحد والعشرين،
أصبحت تمشي بتسارع كبير جداً
إلى درجة أنه إذا احتجت إلى تحديث
معلوماتك بخصوص الجديد بالتكنولوجيا
فالتحديث لمرة واحدة لا يكفي،
إنما ستحدّث يومياً حوالي ست،
سبع، ثماني أو تسع مرات
مَن هنا ليس متخصصاً في المجال التقني؟
أعني لا يدرس هندسة معلوماتية
أو حواسيب وباقي الفروع المشابهة؟
(تفاعل الجمهور)
جميل! تبدون كثراً..
من منكم يستخدم التكنولوجيا
في حياته اليومية؟
نفس العدد!
لا نستطيع أن ننكر أن التكنولوجيا
أساسية ونحن بحاجتها فعلاً،
لذلك يجب أن يكون لدينا
الحد الأدنى من المعرفة فيها.
عندما كنت في الرابعة عشر من عمري تقريباً،
كنت أستخدم الكمبيوتر، لكن كان لدي الفضول
لأعرف كيف يعمل هذا الكمبيوتر.
لماذا يقلع بهذه الطريقة؟
لماذا تُفتَح هذه النافذة عند
الضغط على الزر الفلاني؟
كيف يتم تلوينها وكيف يتم تغييرها
وكيف تنتقل من إطار إلى إطار
ومن نافذة إلى نافذة
حتى أصل بالنهاية إلى
ما أحتاج إلى استعماله؟
عندما عرفت أن هناك ما يسمى علم البرمجة
وهو الذي وراء كل ذلك،
أصارحكم بأنني أصبت بالاكتئاب!
ليس لدي الشغف والاهتمام في أن يصبح
المجال التقني هو تخصصي في المستقبل،
لكن أود أن أشبع فضولي
وأن أتعلم كيف يحدث كل ذلك.
عندها كان دور مهارة التعلم
المستمر بجرعات منخفضة،
استمريت لخمس سنوات،
سجلت في مراكز بحيث أتعلم
في كل أسبوع لمدة ساعتين فقط
حتى استطعت بالنهاية تعلم
لغات البرمجة: C, C#, C++
وأن أدخل إلى عالم الإنترنت
وأتعلم PHP, HTML
والقليل من لغة JAVA.
(تصفيق)
الاهتمام جميل، والهوايات جميلة جداً،
وكذلك الإنجازات التي نحققها طيلة حياتنا.
لكن بالنهاية ما هو تخصصنا؟ ماذا أدرس؟
عندما أنهيت التعليم الثانوي،
توقفت كما يقف جميع الناس
عند فترة اختيار التخصص الجامعي.
في هذه المرحلة، كأي مفصل في حياتك،
يجب أن يبدي الجميع آراءهم وأن يخبروك
ما الذي يجب أن تدرسه أو لا تدرسه.
ويأتي شخص ما، لم يرك
سوى مرة واحدة في حياته
ينظر إليك ويقول: "يليق بك دراسة
الأدب الإنكليزي"
ثم يلتف من الجهة الأخرى
ويقول: "لا، لا،عليك أن تدرس الهندسة،
لكن هندسة ماذا! لا أعرف بوضوح
بسبب الضوء غير الواضح."
نحن نعرف أن اختيار التخصص
الجامعي يعتمد على شقين أساسيين:
أولهما هو كل الأشياء
التي تتدخل باتخاذ قرارك،
والثاني هو تحمل مسؤوليتك تجاه قرارك.
حتى نختار من بين العلوم التخصصية،
يُضاف إلى ذلك شقان إضافيان:
شغفك الكبير بالعلم الذي تود دراسته،
والشروط المطلوبة في نظامنا التعليمي:
العلامات.
عندما حققت الشروط وفكرت
أن أدرس الطب البشري،
كانت ردة الفعل أن لا تدرسي
الطب لأن مشواره طويل، صعب
إذا درست الطب عليك أن تنسي
كل نشاطاتك وهواياتك الأخرى.
وهذه بالحقيقة كانت مشكلة كبيرة نتعرض
لها باستمرار في جميع قراراتنا.
لكن بهذا الوقت، لو نجرب
أن ننسى كل الأقاويل،
الحكم، الاقتباسات، والمشاعر، والأفكار،
أمنيات الغير وتنبؤات الغير بالمستقبل.
ننسى السطور المدونة والعناوين الملونة،
وأن نقوم بالأمر الذي يمليه علينا قلبنا.
دخلت إلى كلية الطب البشري!
ولأن الطب مجال واسع جداً
وهو علم فعلاً صعب الإلمام فيه،
والأصعب هو تقديم ابتكار أو أي شيء يغيره،
لأنه متعلق بالجسم البشري بشكل مباشر،
حيث التجارب صعبة،
وبشكل عام يحتاج التطوير
إلى وقت طويل حتى يعطي نتيجة.
كطالب، كنت أجد أن الطب فيه
نقص بالأدوات وبطريقة التعليم.
الطب معظمه نظري في الوقت الذي
يجب فيه أن يكون في قمة الناحية العملية.
عندما تحدثت بهذا الموضوع مع
رئيس مخبر التشريح في الجامعة،
كان ذلك نواة فكرة تأسيس فريق
ATP - Anatomy Techno Photographers
فريق الدعم التقني لمخبر التشريح.
تجمعنا معاً، تعلمنا القليل من الفوتوشوب
كنا نأخذ صور للمحضرات في مخبر التشريح،
ثم نعود لنعدل عليها، ونضفي إليها
الأسهم والمسميات
حتى حصلنا بالنهاية على أول
أطلس تشريح عربي بالعالم،
وهو ليس فقط عربياً إنما
أيضاً مدعوم باللغة اللاتينية
والتي هي لغة الطب عالمياً.
(تصفيق)
نحن لسنا بحاجة أن نكبر ونتخرج
وأن ندخل مجالات العمل
حتى نطور مجالات دراستنا،
نحن من موقعنا كطلاب وشباب
نود أن نغير، نستطيع التغيير.
ولو بإمكانيات بسيطة،
لكن من الذي سيعرف ما هي
حاجاتنا لعلومنا أكثر منا؟
الشخص الذي تخرّج أو الذي أصبح باحثاً،
لن يكون اهتمامه مصبوباً تجاه
تعليم الطالب في سنواته الأولى
مثلما يكون مصبوباً نحو تطوير
الأشياء التي ضمن مجاله!
لذللك، إذا كنا نود أن نطور،
يجب أن نبادر، وأن نقوم بالأمر
الذي نوده أن يحصل حقاً.
في السنة الماضية، كنت
ضيفة برنامج "سوريات"،
هو برنامج يسلط الضوء على الأنثى
السورية ويستضيف عدة سيدات
برأيهم كنَّ الأكثر تميزاً وإنجازاً.
اللائحة المقترحة للاستضافة كانت طويلة،
هذا إن كان يدل على شيء،
فهو أنه كم لدينا من إناث
قادرات على القيام بالكثير من الإنجازات!
لا أريد أن أقول رغم الصعاب!
الأمر لا يحتاج إلى تحدٍ!
الأمر هو أن يكون لدي الرغبة والشغف،
أتناول الأدوات اللازمة للإنجاز وأقوم به!
حالياً أنا طالبة طب بشري سنة خامسة،
طالبة إدارة أعمال،
عضو لجنة الرياضة الأنثوية،
حصلت على جائزة الشباب
العشر الأكثر تميزاً (TOYP)
من الغرفة الفتية الدولية
(JCI) من فترة قريبة.
وبانتظار ديواني "ألف إنسان في روح واحدة"
ليرى النور!
(تصفيق)
نحن الذين بحاجة إلى أن نرى النور،
قدراتنا بحاجة لأن ترى النور.
لكن نحن يجب أن نؤمّن لها البيئة
التي نستطيع زراعتها فيها
وسقايتها لتعطينا كل ما نريد!
يقول لك أحدهم: "لا أمتلك الوقت،
لا يوجد سوى أربع وعشرين ساعة."
صحيح، لدينا 24 ساعة في اليوم،
لكن لدينا 7 أيام في الأسبوع!
نحن متفقون على أن في حياة
كلٍّ منا مجالاً أو اثنين أساسيين
لا يمكن التغيير في الأوقات المخصصة لها!
هذا الكلام صحيح، لو جربنا تثبيت
الساعات المخصصة لهم،
كم سيزيد لدينا من الوقت؟ ساعتان؟
ثلاثة؟ أربعة؟ ستة؟
وقد يزيد ثمانية ساعات لدى بعض الناس.
لو جربت أن أقوم بشيء مختلف
أو بشيء أحبه وأود أن أكتسبه اليوم
وقمت بشيء آخر في الغد،
في نهاية الشهر ماذا أكون قد استفدت؟
وبعد مرور عام ماذا يكون قد وصلني؟
وبعد خمس سنين ما هو العلم
الذي أكون قد اكتسبته؟
وما الإنجاز الذي أكون قد حققته؟
يجب أن نلاحق ساعتنا،
إن أهم شيء، هو ألا ينتهي النهار
دون أن أمتلك جواباً لسؤال
ما الذي فعلته اليوم!
الطريق صعب،
لكن هل بإرادتنا وبجهدنا سيصبح سهلاً؟
لِمَ لا؟
مازلنا في البداية.
شكراً جزيلاً.
(تصفيق)